he is the CNN anchor and host of who's
talking to Chris Wallace with episodes
available to stream Fridays on HBO Max
and airing Sundays at 7 Eastern on CNN
Chris Wallace
Chris how are you
great to meet you for the second time
welcome to HBO can I show you around the
commissary uh
so you can have we'd have lunch with a
dragon you're gonna love it here Chris
uh you actually are and uh have you have
you found it so far great company right
it is a great company and I this is a
very exciting hybrid because on the one
hand as you just said I'm on HBO Max
three interviews a week drop each Friday
we have three that just dropped today
and then the best parts of those three
interviews on CNN Prime Time seven
o'clock Sunday night so
[Applause]
well I can't think of anybody better to
talk about the news business with I mean
who was more steeped in it obviously
your father was Mike Wallace you worked
for I think your first job was for
Walter Cronkite
well job is a little bit of an
overstatement I was his gopher go for
coffee go for pencils at the Democratic
uh the Republican convention in 1964 the
Barry Goldwater convention yeah right
and Walter Cronkite I mean for those of
people who don't remember this was the
last guy perhaps that everybody trusted
I remember when I was a kid watching TV
and he was the newsman and when a
comedian like wanted to make a joke
about like somebody who had utter
Integrity that was the go-to you know
Walter Cronkite because it was
understood by everybody in America that
this when he said it we both sides
agreed that is a such a bygone world now
that we could even have such a thing no
I I completely agree and in fact in 67
or 68 he went to Vietnam and you know he
was a straight newsman he didn't give
commentary he just reported the facts
but we were in the middle of this of
this terrible and long and bloody war
and he came back and despite what all
the generals were saying he said that
the war is not going well and Lyndon
Johnson the president at the time
supposedly said if I've lost Walter
Cronkite I've lost America right and he
did and he did
it's true it didn't even run again
that's right but today the the some side
probably the right wing would just have
attacked Walter Cronkite no it has
gotten so siled if you will uh you know
you've got you've got conservative media
and they have built up an audience and
they only want to watch conservative
media and what it is that that that uh
you know supports their conception their
view of the world and liberal media and
liberals want to watch that and and to
stressingly few people just want to get
the news and make up decisions for
themselves as to what they think the
truth is
well that's
that's the
that's a very small sliver of the
country I think who even wants news
I mean when I talk to people under 40
even and I ask them where do you get
your news most of what they say is like
well what somebody posts on my Facebook
page in other words it's gossip
like that's to me what gossip is your
friend is passing around a story they
don't know if it's true they don't care
but I mean Walter Cronkite got 29
million viewers
that's I mean nothing no TV show gets
even a third of that even the biggest
hits I don't think anymore in prime time
this was the news
so and and if he got 29 Huntley Brinkley
got 25 or whatever I mean you you had 50
60 million Americans at a time when the
country was a lot smaller who wanted to
tune in to see the evening news I mean
In fairness the world has changed and
you know you don't get your News at 6 30
at night you're getting it all day and
you can get it on you your phone or as
you say Facebook or Instagram or Tick
Tock or whatever but uh it it the world
has has definitely changed and and not
for the better in terms of the the
desire to be to get the straight facts
and to have your preconceptions be
challenged by what reality is people
don't want and reality they want their
View and and this really all came about
because
news used to be a lost leader for a
company it was in Cronkite today
absolutely I mean with the the Giants of
of Television back in the day and that
by that point I mean the the owners Bill
Paley at CBS Sarnoff at NBC they viewed
news as a public service and that you
know it didn't have to make money it it
if it didn't lose money that was that
was okay but even if it lost a little
that was that was all right and and
I got to be careful with this because I
know you're a huge fan of 60 minutes but
I kind of feel that to a certain degree
of 60 minutes and my father were a
little bit responsible for what happened
not that their journalism wasn't
terrific but when 60 Minutes went on the
air in 68 and then as it became more and
more successful it ended up being the
number one show in America for a number
of years
it made money and suddenly the the
executives and television said you can
you can make money with no's and I think
that led to the idea of not having an
audience come to you but chasing an
audience and that led I think to more
biased news coverage